i left i uh kissed the kids goodbye but
i didn't tell them where i'm leaving
they were busy so they were not looking
um my wife of course she knew already
somewhere down the road that something
is not right she felt that you know that
i made a decision which is not gonna
like so
she was upset um
badly uh across the board i was just i
was the only one who was actually going
the other way there was a big queue of
course of
families kids and who are trying to
escape and trying to leave predominantly
women and kids
and
i had a friend of mine who was dropping
off his wife and
their son he was sending him to slovakia
and i crossed where they were crossing
in so they were in the queue so we met
halfway
and then we went back with him and his
wife and child and
and her mother they went and crossed the
border so it's um
it's been a tough journey although it's
been a bit expiry
inspiring because while we were
traveling we met with a lot of well we
drove through a lot of cities and we
seen the
level of
enthusiasm i would say the level of
motivation just local residents you know
they were blocking their roads they were
blocking the roads leading to the cities
to the villages even you know
organizing themselves building
barricades on the roads
uh getting there
hunting guns and you know check making
checkpoints checking for the passports i
mean
the whole nation is extremely motivated
to fire this off it's not like you know
you have the big cities are uh don't
want russia and the rest of the world i
mean it's every single individual in
ukraine they don't want this to come
here
it's insane what is russia trying to do
and now on top they're bombing nuclear
plants with tanks i mean they're
completely out of mind i know the the
general opinion as well because we've
we've known each other for years
and none of them once war
but it's very hard for them for some of
them saying no war or stop war it's
already a
very thin line declaration for the
russian state it is very hard for
professional athletes to call out the
regime because they still have relatives
in that country which can be endangered
so i cannot really ask from the tennis
players to you know come out and say
what they what they want to say it's
impossible well we've been explaining
the basics
and in terms of shooting some test
rounds they said don't worry your time
will have you will come you have plenty
targets to shoot